INTERVIEWER 1: Could you just
tell us a little bit about
maybe what they might be
feeling about now?
ERIC MASKIN: If they feel any
way the way I did four years
ago, they're feeling
overwhelmed.
This day is sensory overload.
You just get hit over and over
again, in a very nice way, but
it's incessant.
MARK WATSON: They're just the
kind of people you what to
copy, these guys.
When the question was asked
about what's your new work?
I think of these guys as being
very excited about their
latest paper, whatever it
happens to be, and that just
rubs off on all of us
in the department.
Again, keeps the excitement high
amongst all the faculty
and all of the students
and everyone.
So congratulations,
and thank you.
THOMAS SARGENT: So as professors
or students, we're
really privileged.
We have a wonderful
life of learning.
You're a person, and you
statistically run into
somebody who knows
more than you do.
And whether or not you could
take advantage of it depends
on how much time you
spend learning.
That's kind of it, nature
just gives you these
opportunities to learn.
CHRISTOPHER SIMS: Now I've
been privileged to be at
Princeton, which is another
great department.
It's a great award, and I'm very
grateful for the award
and for the environment that
I've been in because it helped
me to learn and grow.
So thanks to all of
you at Princeton.
ROHIT LAMBA: A funny thing is
that, when Chris teaches the
advanced macro course, Tom
sits in the class.
And when Tom teaches, Chris
It's amazing, they're these
two old guys who are still
debating about macroeconomics,
they're like 60 years old.
And one can only imagine
what it was like when
they were at Harvard.
PAUL KRUGMAN: If it's anything
like mine, they're totally
having a sort of out-of-body
experience right now.
They're totally shocked,
totally--
it's wild.
FERNANDA MARQUEZ: It was a very
good surprise hearing
about it this morning.
We all feel so privileged to
be here studying in the
Economics Department in
Princeton, and have a faculty
that's been awarded
this great honor.